[Music]
[Applause]
lady gaga
speaking out against vice president Mike
Pence and his wife Karen after the
second lady took a job teaching art at a
school that bans LGBTQ students and
staff he/she hadn't heard about it she's
even an art teacher at a Christian
school I couldn't be more proud of the
pro-life second lady of the United
States of America
[Applause]
[Applause]
is that we there's no prejudice
everybody transgendered life I'm on the
right track baby i was
lady gaga has of course been an
outspoken advocate for the LGBTQ
community since launching her career we
must demand full equality for all they
say that this country is free and they
say that this country is equal but it is
not equal if it's some times every day
we fight to abolish laws that Harbor
hatred and discrimination against all
people laws that infringe on our civil
liberties unfair laws that like Don't
Ask Don't Tell were put in place to
eliminate friction and violence but in
the end only delay the process of ending
this most serious prejudice it has
become clear to me that my greater
mission is to be part of the joyous
mobilisation of the LGBT community
worldwide today and every day we fight
for freedom we fight for justice we
beckoned for compassion understanding
and above all we want full equality
not only me but everyone here we
represent the compassion and the loyalty
of millions of people around the world
that believe in you you are not alone I
[Music]
also believe that kindness is the cure
to violence and hatred around the world
these children are not just homeless or
in need
many of them are trauma survivors
they've been rejected in some type of
way when family was like kind of like
pushing me away because I'm gay all I
can
my own trauma in my life has helped me
to understand the trauma of others
[Music]